Please discuss how discipline in one
area doesn't make up for slack in other
areas. For example, the fit is
guru who has no savings. Mm.
Yeah. You know, this is something
that we all have to work out,
watch out for, is the fact that
we, we focus on our strengths.
That's what we do.
That's what people do.
So you get a person that's smart,
really intellectual person and they let
themselves go physically, right? You know,
or you get a person
that's a physical stud,
but then they're not going to
challenge their brain power.
Or like the question that was,
you know,
the example here that was posed,
someone that's a fitness
guru or a party goofy.
I'm throwing that one out there because
some people are really good that sure.
Or they, you know,
they're an entrepreneur,
entrepreneur and so they're driving
a new Mercedes, but it's at least,
and they're behind on payments.
So strategically yet. Yeah,
yeah. That, um, so you know, I mean,
you take another example is what about
the business person that doesn't have
time for their family, right.
And so that's not good.
So I think the focus here is
we try and we all have to be,
try to be well rounded and not focus so
much on one area that you're going to
let some ed area go. That's target
fixation is what that is, right?
Is you walk into a room and you get
fixated on one target, one bad guy,
you think there's one bad guy.
So you focus all your energy
and then you're getting flanked.
That's target fixation.
You can't let that happen.
You can't let it happen on
the battlefield. You can't
let it happen on the life.
So look out for that when you do this.
Um,
and I'll tell you this is actually
a reality of the situation. Um,
I try and maintain this balance,
but I've been actually
working a lot lately and what,
and this is a clear indicator to me that
I've overbooked myself is last week,
um, we had to, we had to skip
a day of Jujitsu to record.
I mean, we don't do that right? When do
we record? We recorded after Jujitsu.
But I knew I had so much
stuff going on that I said,
hey we gotta we gotta record at this time
cause I gotta get all this other stuff
done because I'm traveling and this and
that until we had to skip the huge it's
called. So that is a red flag
to me that says I need to,
I need to tighten up,
I need to get my,
get my schedule back in check so that
I can do the things that I need to do.
Of course, what do I say about the
situation? It's fine. You know what?
Can't train Jujitsu that day cause I'm
trying, I've got some travel coming up.
Good. I'm going to heal up my shoulder a
little bit more. I'm going to, you know,
I'm going to, it's good, it's fine.
But it is an indicator of when things
start going in the wrong direction.
Maybe I'm getting targeted,
fixated on, you know,
too much work at a certain time,
which to me again,
I will run this thing in the red as you
say. I like, I like running in the red,
right.
I'm in the red and I got no problem.
Like we will go hard and the numbers
of hours I've been where I will work,
we'll have actually no impact on how
much I'm going to tell them to spend with
my family and do Jujitsu and all
that stuff cause I'll just do it all.
But there is a capacity
that you reach where you go.
Okay now one of these things
that is just started to slide.
Now I need to make sure that
my levels get re re levels,
I guess you might say equalized
is what I should have said. Uh,
so back to the subject. Don't
be a one trick pony. You know,
be a jack of all trades and
master a few of those traits.
And so you can emphasize fitness guru,
you can emphasize intellectual power,
you can emphasize Jujitsu,
but don't put 100% of your effort into
one area because eventually it will take
you, you won't have anything else. And by
the way, if you put all your, you know,
if you put all your, all your eggs
in the basket of intellectual power,
now you're unhealthy. And You die,
right. That that doesn't, you know,
I don't care how smart you are. You
can't do two plus two when you're dead.
So don't put all your
focus 100% into one area.
Don't become unbalanced
in your disciplines.
Spread it around and hold the
line. Yeah man, it's good. Yeah.
I guess it kind of feels like,
like you can be understood
that, um, let's see.
I'm real good at, I dunno, fitness
and it's easy to justify
your yourself, you know, like
your, your, let's say, okay,
I'm real good at fitness in the fitness
guru and I go around and then I see on
and all,
I go to the store,
go to some party and I see this
other guy who's like socially,
he's just hundred percent. Everyone
likes him. Such a nice, charismatic guy,
makes a lot of money in on all this stuff,
but he's not in that good a shape or
I don't know. You smokes in whatever,
you know, it's ease. I
think a lot of people,
cool.
It feels like it's easy to justify wolf
that gets in bad shape. So who cares?
I already didn't want any of that. I
wouldn't want all the money, you know,
all this stuff.
It seems like you
got to justify that and you know
if the other guy saying, yeah,
you might be in good shape.
Guessing what? Yeah. Nice.
Toyota Corolla you're driving. He's
all negative on it. Yeah. Yeah.
So both those guys should, you should,
instead of saying, hey, you know what,
they should do, walk up and be
like, hey man, you know what?
I noticed you're pretty
successful financially.
I like to get in the game with you a
little bit and learn from you about that.
Any other guys should say to
them, well, you know what?
It looks like you're in
pretty good at fitness levels.
I would like to get in the game with that.
Let's work together and improve ourselves
and go out and kick ass and dominate.
Are you in, I'm in, let's do this
instead. What does a normal person do?
They do exactly what you
said. Justify, criticized,
cut people down instead
of building them up. Yeah.
And once you have to be careful of,
if I was to go to you and say, hey,
you know echo, I got a lot of money.
I can tell you don't have a lot,
I'll help you out. That's, that can
be offensive to some people. Yeah.
Cause you think dude, who you think
you are at risk and need your help?
I'm going to worry about money.
I think I'm worried about money.
When I got abs like
Yup.
So we have to do is instead of, if
I came to you and said, echo dude,
I want to add is like you got,
can you help me get in the game?
And then we formed a little
relationship and now I say to you, man,
so what do you got? What's your, what's
your main income stream dude? You know,
what are you doing? And you say, well
you know I've got these two clients.
If you've got a website, no, not
really. Why don't you have a website?
Do you got any social media
to advertise on it? You know?
And we go though that road and we
build up. We take care of each other.
That's what we want to do as people.
Yeah.
Kind of like you ever
seen the guys who go,
they see like a football player
or something. It'd be like, Hey,
kick his ass though.
You know,
you know that Kinda guy who can always
like some successful person that he,
I kick his ass though. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well I've told the story in four in the
seat, in the seal teams, it's a, Eh,
no one, no one is good. If a guy, look,
we have guys in the seal teams
that are literally, you know,
world class athletes in whatever world,
class triathlete,
world class, sailor worldclass, whatever.
And so, oh you, oh, you're, you're
world class triathlete. Oh yeah.
That guy is really good traffic.
That's cool. He's a really bad shot.
Someone who's going to chime in and
cut them down and just the way it goes.
Little slack, no slack. Slack.